[Música]
bonita apresentação eu estamos vivendo
em estações está consolidada ok bonita
apresentação e também não poderia deixar
de bonita recepção que eu tive aqui já
hoje por parte destes jovens estudantes
que o cansava por dizer não sintam que
este distanciamento do palco que me
afastar um pouco de vocês não faz
diferente de vocês porque uma das
questões que por vezes me irritava
quando eu estava desse lado e era que
quem é jornalista que era jornalista na
altura quem era já um grande
profissional falava sempre com um grande
distanciamento por exemplo uma das
coisas que diziam quando eu estava no
meu primeiro ano de faculdade mais
interessada nas calmas e nas lotadas era
que uma jornalista que não disse à
imprensa estrangeira nunca poderia ser
jornalista
obviamente que eu com as minhas olheiras
de uma noitada não tinha problema estava
na noite anterior haverá empresas
estrangeiras tsunami também jornalista
eu sou linha na krona é sujo na lista
correspondente da rádio renascença na
região interior centro
só também diretora do notícias google
vai a um jornal da região não sou
jornalista há mais de dez anos e hoje eu
trouxe o saque ou um tema o estranho
caso trabalhar na imprensa regional
eu achei estranho porque vocês vão
perceber logo na minha apresentação que
eu vou partilhar sobretudo o meu
testemunho é falar com verdade falar com
vocês e sobretudo tentar é que vocês
sintam simpatia não só comigo mas com o
meu discurso e sintam motivados a seguir
o mesmo caminho a dar os mesmos passos é
virem para a imprensa regional e
encararem que independentemente dos
ituanos vocês estão seja viseu gol vai a
coimbra amo vocês podem fazer um
trabalho igualmente vistoso na época
quem vai para a comunicação social que
era
o que era pra ser né quer ser visto seja
tudo o que for
seja para divulgar no caso das
reportagens não é divulgar aquilo que o
preocupa fazer um trabalho mais intenso
e portanto eu espero que no final desta
apresentação idéia apresentação como bem
sucedida se eu vir aqui nos nossos
rostos é que ela é que é o sentido do
que talvez seja porque o vosso caminho
ou então passar se é a minha
apresentação
começando pelos meus instrumentos de
trabalho é um saco de ração para gatos e
outro para cão alguém faz a mínima ideia
porque isto me ajuda enquanto jornalista
da rádio pois é o jornalismo anda de
braço dado com o que queria da aci e
vivemos uma conjuntura em que meio parte
dos correspondentes trabalham a partir
cava é as suas instalações às suas
séries nas regiões foram desmantelados e
eu trabalho a partir de casa e para
escutar os outros preciso de silêncio e
por vezes apesar dos meus animais terem
sido todos os campeonatos para casa dos
meus pais por esse motivo mas a minha
porta sempre um gato um cachorro faminto
então tenho sempre um biscoito colocam
um biscoito pagar tom pra eu poder
gravar ou mesmo se passa com o meu
frigorífico que precisava de estar
simpático parece que faz propósito cada
vez que eu vou começar a gravar a
reportagem começa a trabalhar e o que
ele faz
levanta vai desligar o frigorífico e
depois esquece no dia a seguir que
acontece em todo estragado
estas são algumas vicissitudes
curiosidades e também a ser o meu
objetivo jequiti justificar um cadinho
os mitos de quem trabalha nesta nesta
nesta área e esquecem da minha
apresentação de referir que eu comecei
na imprensa regional
manterei licenciatura e jornalismo e
currículos para todo o país
inclusivamente ilhas a de jornais e
televisões locais pra todo lado
três propostas uma de santarém outra do
braga e outro de bragança
optei pela rádio brigantia e bragança
que abriu as portas
onde eu fiz o meu estágio profissional e
não tive convite para parar
vencer mas achei que devia vir para a
minha região e tomar essa opção mas foi
a partir dali daquela rádio local que
muitas vezes os pais de amigos meus
diziam então também vai acontecer
até hoje ele está trabalhos para o ano a
rádio brigantia que é isso
case roni dos empregados em um raro eu
estou a trabalhar há pois pois spasse
copa tv e óptimas tudo tenha só época e
assim também a mensagem seja vocês não
podem querer eu queria na altura os 20
anos estaria a trabalhar assim com 24 né
cada passo tem que ser lado nessa certa
cada vez mais me convenço isso que não
sintam abraçados é como eu vos diz agora
estão mais interessados em sair à noite
do que estudar lá chegará a vós agora o
objetivo da minha presença aqui hoje
também é contar uma história contar
algumas das histórias que eu vivo
diariamente para contar histórias como
dizia há pouco é preciso silêncio é
preciso é preciso entregarmo-nos os
outros intervenientes com os quais nos
cruzamos nesta estrada e faziam mesmo os
incêndios de outubro 2017 renascença por
dilma que eu fizesse um trabalho é para
avaliar se um mês depois o que o que
acontece no terreno e fui para o
conselho de saia sem qualquer referência
às vezes faço isso porque quando temos
melhores resultados sem nada agendado ir
à procura e na estrada que ligava
pequena povoação descida encontram
precisamente no momento em que eu queria
encontrar passado dança alguém
o casal cujo irmão
o casal sim o senhor era irmão da
educação que tenha sido vitimado na
estrada descidas no dia 15 de outubro
quanto tinha regressado a casa para ir
buscar roupa para os filhos
são histórias como estas que
na altura pergunta a irmã eu poderia ter
encontrado tanta gente e foi encontrar
precisamente os familiares que naquele
momento estava a fazer um memorial ao
irmão e respeito e cunhado
ela encontrou na minha presença
lanterna que o irmão tinha transportado
até o momento
eu lembro mas estou porque era essa
história pra vocês também perceberem que
trabalhar na empresa regional não é
fácil
eu lembro que na altura virei costas e
vai ficar assim e assim na imprensa
regional
ou então por exemplo contar histórias
como a de luís cabral luís cabral eu
ligo do número que eu não conhecia o dia
todo insistentemente e eu pensei estou a
trabalhar agora não posso entender não
seja tão resistente que eu atendi luís
pode precisar falar consigo eu sei que
também é diretora do notícias de goiânia
e eu tenho uma história para contar e eu
sentir que vocês vão perceber até um
certo remorso porque eu não fui muito
simpática com estes senhores eu estava a
trabalhar estava sem paciência
ele só estava em pronto a última ea
pressão lá que eu falo com cinco eo luís
às oito e meia da noite alcançadas por
também é o também não é prestar à minha
espera estava com aquele gatinho em
pedra pra não ser brutalmente por que
por que esse carinho por mim e loja
porque eu gostava de partilhar consigo
como eu encontrei refúgio nas pedras da
serra da estrela depois do meu filho tem
fã cidade dez anos ea comissão qualquer
um contou a história e o facto é
esperado por mim o dia tudo para contar
eu senti que ele devia pelo menos contar
a história o melhor que eu soubesse o
quanto a história paranaense para o
tecido ovariano
no terceiro gol do goiás saiu em
diariamente nessa instância também ser
necessário qualquer pedido ou seja é a
história valia por si
vou contar uma história
e como os jogos diz a pouco é
importância de contar histórias e
importância do imprevisto irei o ter
chamado está a apresentação estranho
caso de uma reportagem nos cuidados
paliativos para avaliar o desempenho de
um musicoterapeuta que desenvolvi
musicoterapia josé novais saia
desenvolve musicoterapia junto dos
doentes terminais e eu conhecia a novela
claro nunca mais vou esquecer o nome
dela e até o momento eu entrevistei ela
disse mamãe eu quero ouvir a reportagem
e não vou morrer
estela como vocês podem ver a novela já
não foi a tempo de ouvir a reportagem
essa importância de escutar de escutar
os outros de estarmos atentos quantos de
vocês se escutam escutou a vossa família
há dias num jantar de natal jantar de
natal dos construtivistas de uma zona
não interessa qual uma senhora já idosa
olhou pra mim e disse mann sabiá o
cruzeiro agora é tocar concertina
ministro mas nem sair de sites toca tão
ba em fogo superfície ou agora incentivo
assim porque realmente não tocava mesmo
bairro e uma música só usar aquela
história virou cinzas em sábado
cada vez que minha casa pega uma
concertina os meus netos mandamos está
quieta merece os meus netos nunca viram
tocar e este exercício na nossa
profissão províncias não temos muita
paciência para escutar os outros em casa
já o pai o voa mãe mas nossa profissão
somos obrigados a isso temos que escutar
eu não sei se muitos de vocês querem ser
jornalistas mas também mesmo que não
queira seus jornalistas qualquer
profissão exige se quer você esteja bem
dispostos maldispostos vocês têm que
ouvir ouvir para escutar não pensou que
não pensa que só atrás de histórias
tristes como a história de nery almeida
e parada de gonta tondela ela ter uma
reportagem sobre o exame o que com esse
exame tem a ver
a nossa região não é que ângulo positivo
é que nós poderíamos dar só para não
demonstrar o velhinho numa zona que não
saibam china o telemóvel não sabem nem
sabem nas zonas mais isoladas aqui do
interior
aliás o que é que o interior articulando
o pai à escala mundial é maria almeida
no momento em que eu a contactá ela
descobre por acaso eu vou conhecer o meu
sobrinho neto
o filho da irmã por whatsapp a senhora
percebeu mais fotos ap do que eu tenha
perto de 65 anos ou então é agora teria
que o desafio próprios colocar se vocês
fossem profissionais de jornalismo seu
processo a senhora esta aqui é vitória é
pedir para ouvirem a história dela eu
gostava de perceber se vocês dariam voz
a vitória porque a vitória esteve
correia da inglaterra em 1957 ela que
vive num lar rio torto vocês
acreditariam contraria uma história
desta senhora assim uma primeira
abordagem
eu digo vos que eu desconfiei
eu desconfiei e quando estava a
entrevistar a vitória contava tantos
pormenores da rainha de inglaterra que
eu cheguei ao chelsea pode pensar e
liliana atualmente está a explodir
mas continuarei entrevista montanha
reportagem e no dia seguinte foi para o
ar
eu confesso que estava nervosa não é uma
senhora de 90 anos dizer que se corria
da inglaterra para a cidade mas é um
risco e ocorreu no dia a seguir um
familiar da casa dela tinha ido
trabalhar ainda nova para lisboa uma
casa de família uma casa senhorial
confirma quer existência desta senhora
quer a existência da história de que ela
tenha estado realmente muito próxima da
rainha da inglaterra
o cantor vezes nos leva a acreditar que
existe aqui algum mistério um mistério
de contar histórias o mistério eu quero
que vocês percebam a polícia desta
profissão a beleza de trabalhar de
imprensa regional
por exemplo há mistérios que eu nunca
vou entender e
tenho mais três anos de profissão e
contínuos entender eu fiz
zenas cenas sim zenas pelo menos duas
das reportagens sobre os incêndios de
outubro e nunca nenhuma reportagem teve
tantas partidas como a deste casal do
tabu que no final deste ano e neste
dezembro de 1 km da casa delas estão a
viver numa garagem
segundo natal consecutivo fora de sua
casa e esta notícia teve mais partilhas
que todas as notícias que eu tinha feito
anteriormente sobre os incêndios
qualquer uma delas porque seria natal
800 partilhas em algumas páginas do
facebook que não tinham nada a ver se
escrevem com incêndios nem cor nascença
e nem tanto porque a notícia faz parte
do mistério o mistério que leva por
exemplo um calendário calendário dos
rostos mais belos da serra da estrela é
cera destaca em órgãos do mundo e é hora
de assinar espalhados pelo mundo
só vou falar disso mas é só perguntar
mas quando vocês e que numa primeira
abordagem parceria olhar para um pastor
de um ângulo sexy
um senhor de 81 anos que influenciou
mente este ano já faleceu mas ainda foi
a tempo de ser abrir se uma capa do
calendário o que vocês conseguem olhar
por um pastor e vira lhe inglesa nós
tentávamos encontrarmos dos fizeram
kasten tivemos muita procura muito
pastor bonito muito ângulo para ver e
fotografar os em 12 fotografias que a
capa sem o el mundo
o jornal espanhol e no dia a seguir à
apresentação do calendário foi destaque
na euronews conhecem o canal euronews e
quando ligam a dizer olha a atenção que
o calendário está a passar na euronews
se você não enviou nenhum comunicado à
imprensa para áreas onde estava saco com
as imagens do beiral tv um canal local
o canal de televisão local
e lá ia o senhor tabela desfilar e todos
os outros postos o que interessa aqui é
o local onde estava a fazer este
trabalho que entrou e está no aguardo do
estado no horário gostar é no mínimo
seja onde for
deixou uma frase e tal como eu vos diz é
inicialmente eu espero que sim então
egos atos e que entendam esta pretensão
de contar histórias locais não é que o
que nos falava mais uma rua da aldeia
global não interessando vocês estão
então essa história a história sempre
comprada sempre vendida sempre
interessava se ela tiver em 3
não entendo como se pode ser jornalista
sem ser primeiro um bom ser humano da
jornalista diana andringa obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]